[Music]
Andrew started his Tick Tock account in
July of 2021 and he posted all the
typical things videos of friends of work
his girlfriend his dog and just goofing
around but starting in April 2022 his
post would take a strange turn and
Andrew Dawson would become the center of
one of the biggest internet mysteries in
years every story I cover on this
channel is a suggestion from you and
almost every one of them falls into one
of a few categories UFOs government
cover-ups Men In Black missing persons
and Giants well today's episode has all
of these this is the strange story of
Andrew Dawson
foreign
ER Dawson going by the handle
handicapped was just another guy on Tick
Tock although Tick Tock is full of
people posting conspiracy videos Andrew
wasn't one of them his videos reflected
the life of a nice normal guy 34 years
old living in British Columbia good job
nice friends close relationship with his
girlfriend and her kids that's probably
why he wasn't prepared for the rabbit
hole he was about to go down on April
9th 2022 Andrew was driving with a
friend when he spotted something on the
ridge of whistler's peak in Alberta
Canada
what is it
person dude
no seriously pull over pull over
although his friend wasn't convinced
Andrew said it was a person but at that
Zoom from that distance whatever this is
it was way too big to be a person well
too big to be a normal sized person
standing there no it's not
dude if you've seen what I've seen right
now
that video got millions of views
yeah they do keep saying that but you
know I don't like cryptage I know you've
said right well which is more important
what you like or views
views well better learn to love stories
about Bigfoot chupacabra and the crab
kit there's no such thing as a craft be
the crab cat thousands of people in
Andrew's comments wanted him to get
closer to the mountain and try to find
out exactly what the object was e r on
our way we're gonna go find somewhere
closer and I'm gonna set my camera on
something so you guys aren't complaining
how shaky it is in the truck
because yeah
internet has no chill I have to agree
with Andrew on that one the internet
definitely has no chill just look at all
the comments on YouTube shorts
but that's the mountain we're going to
just gonna try to get closer
Andrew's friend didn't think it was a
giant he just thought it was a tower or
some large structure on the ridge but it
couldn't have been a tower
because when Andrew went back to look
for it it was gone
okay I'm gonna use this as a tripod to
try to keep it steady for you guys and
it's not even there anymore too
foreign
that's where it was yesterday
Andrew spoke to a few locals about what
he thought was a giant residents told
him that something lives in the
mountains but it's not always visible
I spoke to some locals and it comes and
goes apparently I don't know
see that's me trying to keep it super
steady when something's paranormal do
you know how hard it is to keep it
steady with zoomed in all the way
this area of Canada has had over 200
Bigfoot or Sasquatch sightings going
back to the 1800s and native tribes in
this area have a legend about Sasquatch
that goes back a thousand years in fact
the word Sasquatch comes from the Salish
word for wild man or hairy man the last
Sasquatch sighting was in 2014 when the
news reported a bigfoot-like creature
walking through the snow near Whistler
pretty sure
Sasquatch down there I can't really see
it very well there's this little black
dot walking in the middle of the snow in
the middle of nowhere
[Music]
that is pretty big
I can't zoom in anymore
this guy's just scampering up snow lands
it was no big deal
this is Jasper National Park the same
area locals gave Andrew directions to
the location where he saw whatever it
was that he saw but even though he was
driving on a public Road in a national
park he was stopped by some type of
government agent
I just got stopped by like some CIA
agents he told me to turn around and
said I'm trespassing I said it's a
public freaking it's a public area like
a public park or whatever some local
told me to take this path
I didn't get it on camera but I'm gonna
go again tomorrow and be prepared to be
filming right now because he stopped the
vehicle his truck was blocking it said
some like environmental issues going on
I don't know it was he told me to go
back and said I was trespassing
I don't get it
it was awkward but I'm going back again
tomorrow to see if he's not there but if
he is there I will keep camera I will
film because the only angle I could get
that that I found today is the one I
just posted earlier and it wasn't even
anything there
but I don't understand why the road's
blocked off
I
I don't know
now I've read some debunkers on Reddit
that challenge this CIA idea yeah I read
it huh what do those Geniuses have to
say well they say that the CIA doesn't
operate in Canada
oh it hurts it hurts me I like gave
myself a stitch
hey Reddit the CIA operates everywhere
they operate everywhere and even if you
think the CIA doesn't operate in Canada
which is adorable if you believe that
Canada's intelligence agency the csis
operates everywhere and that's who could
have stopped him or did he go back the
next day yup did he record it yup hot
chilula foreign
[Music]
left the house early to head back to the
mountain to try to find the creature
all right I woke up actually today
[Music]
Rex are we gonna go on an adventure
it's currently
5 30 in the morning
I'm gonna see if he's there early in the
morning and see if I can get up a little
bit look at all these mountains I got
they are everywhere around here too
that's the one
all right let's go on Andrew's trip back
to the mountain he recorded a couple of
more strange events
that's
that looks like many other UFO sightings
in the area but things get even stranger
Andrew then spotted this over the
mountain
solder extracting
something out of here there's two
helicopters
the
black helicopters
it's happening on Andrew's drive to the
mountain within the same hour or two now
he looked all over but he couldn't find
the Giant in the mountains but later
that evening he does find the road where
he was stopped previously and just like
he said there is an agent there in an
unmarked car the agent once again tells
Andrew the road's closed
the guy's here again
yeah it's just this is him
what's going on
road's closed turn around really yeah
man just just turn around please
okay okay
have a good night man Andrew doesn't
argue he turns his car around and heads
home
oh that was up
here he is I'm driving past him again
just turned around
I don't understand why it's closed off
though it's a public park
or public road or whatever
but whoever that agent was it wouldn't
be the last time we see him
Andrew didn't post any videos for a few
days but soon we would learn why on
April 16th he uploaded a video titled
being stalked
thank you
I think that's the same vehicle from
hey
things just got real they did that looks
like the same unmarked Dodge Charger
from the last video the mountain is
pretty far from Andrew's house so
whoever stopped him on the dark Road
somehow found out where he lived and was
watching him from the street but he
can't get some balls to run out there
like that he does but like I said Andrew
isn't a conspiracy black helicopter men
and black believer he probably doesn't
understand how dangerous this move was
his fans tried to explain this to him
after he posted that video people in his
comments told him that this was a stupid
idea and he needs to be really careful
then people got really nervous when
Andrew didn't post a follow-up he had
been uploading videos pretty
consistently everything that's happened
so far took place in a single week but
then nothing rumors on Tick Tock began
running wild people speculated that he
was abducted or maybe something worse
finally after three weeks Andrew returns
with another video but this one is very
different than the others it's called
official update hey guys
I just want to give you an update I'm
not dead I have not disappeared
I have just been busy with life I
couldn't get around to post it and
updating you guys so now I'm gonna give
you an official update of what's been
going on
sorry to disappoint you guys but all of
the videos that I post all the videos
that I posted were scripted they're just
fake they were just strictly for an
entertainment
I sorry to disappoint you guys I just
need to give you a quick update and not
suspicious at all Andrew is leaning up
against the plain wall with his hands in
his pockets he never posts like this and
in every other video he's posted he
records himself but in this video the
phone or camera is on a tripod also this
video has a slightly different aspect
ratio than his other videos which means
different phone oh no and look at his
eyes doesn't it seem like he's looking
at someone else in the room many people
pointed out that it looked like Andrew
was forced into making this video people
continued to speculate about whether or
not Andrew was coerced but 10 days later
we would learn the truth from Andrew
himself
you might not see meatballs ever again
my videos weren't they weren't fake
for the caption of that video Andrew
wrote too much has happened and I can't
be forced to be silent Andrew was
finally ready to tell the world what
happened to him the following day he
would upload another video
Andrew's life had become complicated a
story that began as simple curiosity
about a tall figure on a mountain
descended into a saga where Andrew's
being followed and watched by a
mysterious agent working for an unnamed
agency but he's forced to record a
confession retracting everything he said
in his videos and then retracts that
retraction 10 days later saying the
videos were real now clearly whoever
forced his confession was following his
Tick Tock account but the big question
was who well Andrew might have given us
a clue when he posted a video the
following day titled military
what is that
that was not there yesterday
so we've got a sighting of a humanoid
figure or some kind of structure on a
local mountain that disappears the
following day strange objects in the sky
over the mountain helicopters circling
and carrying large equipment either in
or out of the area and government agents
closing public roads then surveilling
and possibly abducting people and now an
ominous black structure that was
literally built overnight in only a
month Andrew went from a happy fun
regular guy to anxious and paranoid it's
not paranoia If people really are
following you that's true on May 13th
Tony Merkel host of the confessionals
podcast reached out to Andrew on
Instagram about a possible interview
Tony didn't hear back but a little over
a month later on June 23rd Andrew
responded Tony asked Andrew if the
videos were real or a prank Andrew said
all fake everything's fake it's fake
then Andrew asked why what did you see
Tony posted a link to Andrew's
confession Andrew wrote back that he
can't say anything about it and that it
didn't happen Andrew didn't tells Tony
he shouldn't be talking to him and to be
safe the video of the structure on the
mountain was Andrew's last tick tock
video but he kept posting on Facebook
Andrew's Facebook posts were mostly
pictures of family and friends jokes and
random positive thoughts he was excited
about a trip to Mexico that he just
booked it seemed like Andrew Dawson was
ready to put the entire Mountain Mystery
behind him and get on with his life
unfortunately that wouldn't be possible
Andrew's followers fell into one of two
camps one the people who wanted him to
keep digging for more answers to keep
posting videos of what he found and the
other Camp people telling Andrew that he
stumbled into a very dangerous situation
and by posting these videos which were
being seen by millions of people he
could be putting his life in danger his
fans urged him stop posting videos about
whatever this was they told him to hire
a lawyer and go to the media they felt
the only way Andrew could protect
himself was to get his story Into the
news but even though Andrew said he
wouldn't remain silent that's exactly
what he did he didn't post any more
videos he declined interview requests he
didn't say another word about this but
he did show up in the local newspaper
about a week later oh he went to the
media huh good idea nope he didn't go to
the medium what was in the paper Andrews
obituary oh no on July 1st about six
weeks after Andrew's final Tick Tock
video his obituary appeared in the
Campbell River mirror speculation online
went wild was his death a coincidence or
is this yet another example of a
whistleblower suddenly disappearing and
what was it that Andrew saw on the
mountain if anyone was looking for
closure on these Mysteries they weren't
going to get it Andrew Dawson passed
away on July 1st 2022 he was only 34
years old
Andrew Dawson's story was one of the
biggest internet Mysteries of the year
but is it true well let's take it step
by step the video that started all this
was the Giant on the ridge now I've seen
this mountain reported as Whistler Peak
but it's not that Ridge is actually
canoe Mountain Andrew took this video
while driving South on bc5 or Yellowhead
Highway we know this because at the very
beginning of his video we see the sign
for a cedarside Regional Park
now if we follow Andrew's route and grab
images that aren't overcast you can see
this is the right mountain and if we
zoom into that Peak we can see the
object what Andrew thought looked like a
giant was just the top of a cell phone
tower but the reason the tower
disappeared in a later video is because
he was recording a little further down
the highway where the road veers to the
West that puts the tower out of you the
UFO video was taken over a different
mountain now while this could be a UFO
it's probably just contrails the reason
it looks bright orange is because the
video was taken while the sun was coming
up now the helicopter video is fun lots
of stories we cover seem to have black
helicopters circling around but that's
not what's Happening Here what Andrew
saw is called hella logging this is when
helicopters are brought in to remove
trees from inaccessible areas and that
building that Andrew saw that was
actually the Jasper Sky tram even how
did he build that overnight they didn't
it was built in 1964. so was Andrew
hoaxing or did he really not know about
the SkyTrain Ram he's from the area so
it's safe to say that he knew about it
and I'm sure that wasn't the first time
he saw a helicopter carrying logs so far
Andrew's story isn't panning out but
things do get a little more complicated
when it comes to the CIA agent or
whoever that was it was definitely the
same car that was on the Mountain Road
and that tore away from his house but
was this guy a government agent it's
hard to tell from the footage there are
a few frames where we see him fairly
close up but if he's a man in Black he's
the first one I've seen to wear stretchy
pants tucked into Timberlands well maybe
Canadian Men In Black outdoorsy and
fashionable could be but I'll leave that
up to you to decide but the agent
doesn't sound like law enforcement
roads closed turn around really yeah man
just just turn around please yeah man
just just turn around please kind of
casual ever been pulled over and
initially the officer is standoffish and
kind of robotic that's not them being a
jerk police are trained to establish
Authority at the beginning of an
encounter this guy doesn't sound like a
cop to me and definitely not like a Fed
yeah man just just turn around please
now the quote unquote agent was driving
a 2015 Dodge Charger we know that some
Canadian law enforcement agencies use
that vehicle but if it's a government
vehicle why does it have an aftermarket
exhaust system hey
[Music]
morning
and that was not professional
surveillance you don't park right in
front of the target's house with the
motor running and the lights on as far
as tradecraft goes that's a huge fail
and highly suspicious now Andrew's
forced confession was definitely odd but
it doesn't feel right to me when Andrew
looks off camera it looks forced like
he's over acting Andrew was an aspiring
musician and was excited about all the
views he was getting on Tick Tock we
know he liked performing for the camera
we could be watching a performance here
but I could be wrong maybe he's being
sincere but if he really was forced into
making this video I think it's strange
that the image he used for the thumbnail
was of him looking away like he's
calling attention to it you think
whoever forced him to make the video
would have prevented him from using that
frame and calling attention to it oh
maybe he was giving us a signal that
someone was in the room with him maybe
but if a government would go to the
trouble and take the risk of abducting a
person and forcing them to post a tick
tock video that government could just as
easily force him to remove all the
videos about the mountain or force him
to delete his account or just delete the
person who owns the account which they
did right Andrew's death is the
strangest part of this whole story and
still there are a few details that don't
add up
we've been able to explain just about
every one of Andrew's videos I think
we've solved everything he saw on or
around the mountains or at least we've
made pretty strong cases for a hoax but
Andrew's death is not so easy to solve
there are aspects of it that feel like a
hoax but there are aspects that make me
think he might actually be gone Andrew's
obituary did show up in the local paper
on July 1st but anyone can post on that
newspaper's website without a death
certificate looking at the source code
of the page we can see that his obituary
was first published on July 1st at 7am
but he died on July 1st so did he pass
away very early in the morning and then
someone submitted an obituary to the
paper just a few hours later that's odd
to me now there have been at least two
people who have confirmed Andrew's death
they allegedly said he was depressed and
took his own life now could they be part
of the hoax in covering sure but faking
your own death isn't easy his Facebook
page has been changed to a remembering
page that attracts a lot of attention
Andrew's girlfriend created a couple of
videos after his passing that looked
pretty sincere
well most of them do now I don't love
the idea of posting tick tocks about
your partner's death that seems weird to
me why put something so painful and
personal online you're such a boomer
yeah I know I've been told that this is
not that unusual for tick-tockers to me
it feels a little unseemly but everyone
processes grief in their own way by the
way I'm not going to link to her social
media if you really want to find her
it's easy enough to do but please don't
comment on her posts or reach out to her
just leave her alone every comment she
gets is what happened to Andrew and if
he really is gone then all those
comments have to be torture now some
other things are strange there's very
little information about Andrew online I
couldn't find birth records death
records residences phone numbers what
schools he went to employment history
arrest records or really records of any
kind the only background information I
could find comes from his Facebook page
but I could find members of his family I
found his grandfather who Andrews named
after I found his mother I found his
siblings I thought it was strange that
his sister posted nothing about the
passing of her brother on her social
media and she posts every day now if he
really is gone his family has my
condolences but if he's alive then he
has my congratulations if this is a hoax
it's a good one if it's not a hoax it's
really really sad
[Music]
with me
foreign
yeah I really hope this is a hoax and at
some point Andrew reappears maybe he
posts a tick tock video explaining
everything and how difficult it was to
keep the secret for so many months then
he could live his life raise his kids
and when they grow up tell them the
story about how daddy fooled everyone on
the internet
something tells me he's never going to
get that chance
[Music]
foreign
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the Y files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor like
subscribe comment share that stuff
really helps the channel and like most
topics we cover on this channel today's
topic was recommended by you so if
there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips a special thanks to our patrons who
made this channel possible without you
guys there'd be no channel so thanks for
everything that you do and if you'd like
to support the channel consider becoming
a member on patreon or grab something
from the Wi-Fi store
fight people surveyed say coffee tastes
better coming out of a lizard people mug
four out of five huh hey it's just
science you say so that's gonna do it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you